foreign
there's a clip I want to play
from a 2018 shareholder meeting with uh
our friends I wish they were my friends
Warren Buffett and Charlie Munger very
very wealthy old men and uh it's talking
about cryptocurrency and I'll tell you
why I played it afterwards but let's get
your take on this clip from the 2018
shareholder meeting
they're nothing being produced in the
way of value from the asset that
you also have the problem that it draws
in a lot of charlatans in that sort of
thing who are trying to create various
sorts of exchanges or whatever it may be
it you know it's something where where
people who were of less than star
character see an opportunity
to
clip people who were trying to get rich
because their neighbors getting rich
buying this stuff and neither one of
them understands
it will come to a bad ending Charlie
well
I like crypto currencies a lot less than
you do
and so to me it's just dementia and I
think the people who are professional
traders that go into Trading
cryptocurrencies
it it's
it's just disgusting it's like somebody
else is trading turds and you decide I
can't be left out
gosh I love this so much I feel like you
would fit in well on that stage talking
about your disdain and yeah I've always
thought I was an old soul and I'm like
these are the guys I want to hang out
with these are my people Warren and
Charlie need a podcast okay so let me
recap in case you didn't hear what they
said Warren Buffett said that
cryptocurrency draws in a lot of
charlatans who are trying to create
various sorts of exchanges whatever it
may be it's something where people who
are of less than Stellar characters see
an opportunity to clip people who are
trying to get rich because their
neighbors getting rich buying the stuff
that neither one of them understands it
will come to a bad ending his friend
Charlie Vice chairman of Berkshire
Hathaway which is Warren's uh investment
firm holding company said crypto is like
somebody else trading turds and you
decide I can't be left out
and that is the definition of fomo and
what this kind of get rich quick crypto
greed culture has turned into and
there's a reason I played this clip from
four years ago who knew it was
foreshadowing Christina because the news
came out this week
that one of the largest cryptocurrency
exchanges FTX
just filed for chapter 11 bankruptcy and
the collapse is being compared to Enron
and Bernie Madoff and it is a wild wild
story
so the company's founder Sam bankman
freed faces allegations that he secretly
transferred 10 billion dollars from FTX
to Alameda research which is his hedge
fund that also filed for bankruptcy and
there's he's facing a criminal probe in
the Bahamas for this and it it's not
going to end well and he went from a 16
billion dollar net worth to a zero
dollar net worth because of this
collapse and all of the users that have
accounts may never see the money again
if their accounts went down to zero and
now they're gone where where did it
happen here and uh a lot of people have
compared this to Lehman uh I would
compare to Imran one said
and this is crazy just a crazy story and
it really goes back to what those old
guys were talking about which are some
of the wealthiest smartest guys in the
financial World which is that there's so
much fraud and delusion in the
cryptocurrency world and it's a sad
thing to see I think so many people just
want it to work because they want that
get rich quick feeling they want to have
success instantly it's been interesting
talking to people who you know are
obsessed with crypto being somebody in
the money space you know it's like I
want to tell me more tell me more I want
to understand why you're so passionate
about this they're so much nicer than I
am Christina Well it's hard because like
a lot of them don't have answers for how
it works it's like wait how is your
money saying you don't understand the
blockchain Christina it's like this is
the future man you're so out of touch
oh my gosh and and here we are
at its peak it was the third largest
crypto exchange and it's just gone kaput
and millions of dollars worth of assets
just unaccounted for yeah that's scary
very scary and so I love I'm a big fan
of Warren Buffett so much wisdom uh one
of the wealthiest people on planet Earth
97 billion dollar net worth and I just
wanted to share some of the ways that he
lives that I think we can all take away
and live a little bit smarter a little
less uh frivolous if you will so here's
an article that covers some of that one
uh buy a modest home he says he still
lives in the same home in Omaha Nebraska
that he had since the 50s and the dude
has as much I mean he could buy islands
for days right I love this one that says
don't be afraid to use coupons in front
of friends my man and he talks about or
I guess Bill Gates talks about a story
where they were at a McDonald's in Hong
Kong and Buffett offered to pay and he
dug into his pocket and pulled out
coupons to pay for Bill Gates meal I
love that so much that's that's amazing
another one look for sales and Deals
this one I'm personally passionate about
I'm very I call myself bougie Frugal I
like the Finer Things in life but I'm
still going to get a deal on it and I'm
going to be very intentional
um and this is something he's very
passionate about is doing the research
can I get a better deal on this
negotiate all that stuff that's good I
like that he also says don't gamble that
gambling is a tax on ignorance I think
that's really important especially now
with all the online gambling and it's
like gambling is getting so mainstream
it's you watch a football game and
there's all these different commercials
encouraging you to gamble and you can do
sports betting and you can bet on the
tiniest little pieces of the game yeah
and you think well I'm just having some
fun and all of a sudden you're like I
just blew 500 bucks this month yeah or
I'm hooked on it and I feel like I can't
stop I mean it's becoming an addiction
an actual legitimate addiction or you
think I'm gonna be the next Powerball
winner and win two billion dollars right
uh there's there's a much higher chance
you get struck by lightning a thousand
times in the same spot than winning that
Powerball uh and we've we've called the
lottery attacks on the poor and very
similar to what Buffett says here yeah
and then he also says forget fancy food
which I feel like we can all get on
board with that you know he said he he
literally could afford Lobster you know
for every single meal but he's really
cautious with what he eats and is
mindful of that so I mean for all all
y'all on beans and rice you know maybe
you maybe you stick with that a lot
you're just living like Warren Buffett
that's all there you go yeah well Dave's
always said you know you eat enough
Lobster it tastes like soap eventually
and so even the Finer Things in life you
know at some point it's it loses its its
specialness if you will another one
don't upgrade possessions unless you
have to Buffett famously use the Nokia
flip phone for years although he's moved
on to an iPhone my man you know he would
he has standards Christine he's like I'm
not getting an Android all right I want
to enjoy life oh that's a good one
that's awesome I like that he also said
pick inexpensive hobbies his favorite
hobby is playing bridge and that if he
ever went to jail he would hope that his
friends in jail would play with uh play
bridge with him please don't go to jail
Warren we need you you're a Voice of
Truth in a world gone mad
uh the last one here that I think is fun
is forget fancy clothing yes you know
just go to Steve Jobs route just wear a
turtleneck every day you think I should
do that Christina I'm on board with that
I like simplifying I get I'd get too
claustrophobic it's too much fabric for
me guys let's stop it at the neck any
more than that
oh good stuff there a lot of Timeless
wisdom though in a lot of what they said
and I've I've said on the show now for
months and months if you follow the
trends you will fall for the traps and
anytime something comes on the horizon
that everyone gets a little you know
starry-eyed about I go oh I'm gonna step
back
is this does this have a proven track
record what's behind this thing and
Warren Buffett said he wouldn't buy all
the crypto in the world for 25 all the
Bitcoin because it produces nothing and
you can see what happens when nothing is
produced it's a house of cards and the
whole thing can just collapse and so
only invest in things with long-term
track record even when it's boring and
that's what we found in a millionaire
study is that it's 401ks and paid for
real estate and IRAs and mutual funds
that's what causes long-term wealth and
what causes you to keep it yeah and it
may not look as fun and flashy in the
moment you may not you know have instant
success but it's what is going to stand
the test of time yeah and I've I've made
the analogy that it's like popcorn in
the microwave and you've been there
Christina when it goes one second too
long in the microwave and it's burnt
like how did the it was in there one
second too long I had 16 billion in the
bank the other day and now it's zero
that's exactly it and you're gonna get
burnt Christina if you live the
microwave lifestyle and so I need
everyone listening to be a crock pot in
a world full of microwaves it tastes
better you don't have to worry about it
no one's freaking out about what's on
the crock pot it's gonna be fine it'll
be fine and so be patient the Bible says
Proverbs 13 11 wealth gained hastily
will dwindle but whoever gathers little
by little will increase it so good
Timeless wisdom right there